there's antimony arsenic aluminum
selenium and hydrogen and oxygen and
nitrogen and rhenium and nickel
neodymium neptunium germanium and iron
americium ruthenium uranium europium
zirconium lutetium vanadium and
lanthanum and osmium and astatine and
radium and gold and protactinium
Natalia there's yttrium ytterbium
actinium rubidium born gadolinium
niobium iridium is strontium and silicon
and silver and samarium and bismuth
bromine lithium beryllium and barium
there's holmium and helium and hafnium
and erbium the phosphorus and francium
and fluorine and terbium and manganese
and Mercury molybdenum magnesium
dysprosium and scandium the cerium and
cesium there's lead praseodymium and
platinum plutonium palladium promethium
potassium polonium and tantalum
technetium titanium tellurium and
cadmium a calcium of chromium and curium
there's sulfur californium and fermium
berkelium and also mendelevium
einsteinium nobelium and argon Krypton
neon radon xenon zinc and rhodium
chlorine carbon cobalt copper
Constantine and rhodium these are the
elements in Hobart Harbor but those who
studied chemistry soft petersburg's
university would all unanimously agree
my apologies to Gilbert & Sullivan and
Tom Lehrer